i am not on any social media i i i it's
antithetical to my beliefs but here i am
doing this
yes hello gq i'm nicholas cage and today
i'm going undercover on the internet
it's actually me it's it's nick cage
i read it there is a song that i devoted
to you have you heard of this i heard
about it i did hear that reddit has a
sub something about me you know what
it's called yeah i've heard about it i'm
not going to say it
that would be arrogant
what movie role would have been improved
by casting nicholas cage i can't answer
that either because that would be
arrogant for me to determine what i
would have been better at than somebody
else next
til that nicholas cage spent 150 million
on a 70 million year old dinosaur skull
there's the skull i bought at an auction
and i bought it legally here's the
mcguffin when the mongolian government
said that they needed it back i gave it
to him but i never got my money back so
somebody at the auction house should be
in jail
t-i-l nicholas cage and gary ullman were
the original choices to play harry and
lloyd really
i didn't know that
i thought it was jim from the beginning
i know jim wanted me to be in it with
him but i wanted to do a little movie
called leaving las vegas instead
what would the most annoying sound in
the world have sounded like though
wanna hear the most annoying sound in
the world
i don't know how to answer that
in 1997 tim burton wanted to make a
superman movie starring nicholas cage
why can't they just make this now
would it matter how much time i appeared
as the character
it might still be a chance
posted
wikipedia
well wikipedia is something that people
go in and they change
any way they want so i'm not sure all
the facts are true in wikipedia but at
15 years old he tried to commit to his
uncle francis vorkova to give him a
screen test telling him i'll show you
hacking that's in fact yeah that did
happen and i was met by silence in the
car
next
for birdie in order to physically feel
the pain of his character cage removed
two teeth without any anesthesia yeah
anesthesia yeah that that's a fact but
so you don't think i'm completely out of
my mind i had to pull the baby teeth out
anyway the timing of it worked out it
made me seem like a method lunatic but
the truth is it was something i had to
do anyway
next
in february 2011 he realized that he had
developed his own method of acting which
he described as nebosh shamanic he noted
at some point i'll have to write a book
nuboshamanic is something i came up with
because i like the french sound nouveau
i thought it had a kind of a fun sound
meaning new i had read a book called the
way of weird by brian bates and he was
putting forth the notion that all actors
whether they know it or not
are recruiting the same instincts of the
early shamans
in the old villages from
hundreds and thousands of years ago and
i like that idea the idea of exploring
your imagination so that's where that
came from
and have you written the book yet no
youtube
[Music]
whoever thought that nicholas cage would
play as spider-man spider-man noir was
great i really enjoyed playing that part
i liked it because i was able to bring
some of my own personal interests in the
early actors of the 30s and 40s like
bogart and cagney that were in all those
noir films so that was fun for me and
they let me do it which is unusual
replied
[Music]
this is the greatest casting of all yeah
but that that was something that didn't
happen this uh
nicholas cage is joe exotic and it's
probably just as well it seemed like a
fun character to play but i have nothing
in common with joe exotic
quora
how did nicholas cage think about the
decision to name his son kalel kalel is
a hebrew name and it means voice of god
it's also from a very famous character i
think it's a beautiful name so that's
why
in ghostwriter nicholas cage's abs real
they are real and that's why i will
never work out that hard again because
nobody wanted to believe they were real
they wanted them to believe it was cgi
which it wasn't
so what's the point
has nicholas cage ever turned down a
movie over all the time i know that's
not the urban myth you want it to be but
i turn him down all the time
twitter
tattoo phase off nichols case versus
john travolta winner
oh it's got to be travolta has to be
travolta
speed round fave nicholas cage meme i
kind of like the vampire one right off
the bat this early picture of me i like
that because it's an early black and
white picture i think it looks pretty
cool how do you feel about memes with
you in general
what am i gonna do about it it's there
tick-tock
i have no
relationship with tick-tock whatsoever
nicholas cage plays nick cage
what if nick cage didn't get the role
well i think that would have been
fascinating to see someone else play me
which was my first suggestion but they
didn't want to go for that they said
they had to have the real me whatever
that means
posted
okay that's it i'm signing off